so are aliens real
probably
there's no we we life started on earth
pretty quickly
with almost as quickly as
the environment allowed we had
self-replicating life there's a place
out in joshua tree that's out here in
the desert uh called the integratron oh
i've been there i've done it well let me
tell you the story behind it please we
don't want to tell them for those who
don't know what integrotron is
describe integrtron and then tell your
story
very unique cool
is the middle of joshua tree it's a
giant half dome probably 75 feet across
like a big half down it's got an
armature meaning something go around the
outside with some things sticking in if
you go on the inside you can hear a
little bit of an echo i was out there
visiting a friend and i was much younger
than i am right now and they told me
about this guy named dr george von
tossel and his wife doris who built
something called an integratron in the
middle of the desert and there's a lot
of flying saucers out there or viewings
of flying saucer she says believe me
you're meant to go there
but i just don't get how they can keep
it hidden
well they hide in plain sight back in
the early 90s after i'd briefed the cia
director i had a guy who was on the
committee dealing with the secrecy
um that had been lying to president
clinton uh and he said look we just hide
this in plain sight we put this out
there in a way
that is the public is aware of it i mean
i think after pornography the number one
search thing on the internet are ufos
but the problem is is that they attach
the false narrative to it
so
it's sort of like the way
counter intelligence works and false
information works you put a little bit
of truth at the center of it
like those tic tac those craft that our
navy jets chased off the coast of
california it's been on all the news for
the last two or three years the pentagon
has affirmed that those are real ufos
but they attach in every article this
statement that it's a national security
threat so they're they're now gone from
pop culture and movies in hollywood and
the ufo subculture sort of fringe to the
mainstream media and now from the
director of national intelligence due in
june is this report
that was ordered in the covet bill
signed in december 27th they have 188
180 days to get that out so i'm trying
to get more of this information out
including
showing the models and the aircraft that
were developed through my uncle's
company and lockheed skunk works
back in the 50s 60s 70s and they
continue to be developed that have been
kind of hoaxing events the very first
experience
was
and i don't talk about this very often
but you ask so i will uh i was
electrocuted
when i was five years old
and
burned severely burned all my eyebrows
my eyelashes all i still have scars in
my arms from it
obviously i lived
and in those days the doctor used to
come to the house in in missouri i was
in northern missouri it was in broad
daylight and i remember i had i had had
this
jolt
of electricity
that shot through my body and i couldn't
talk
i was
not really paralyzed but i for whatever
reason i couldn't speak
my mom had called the doctor i was
waiting for the doctor and while i was
waiting for the doctor in broad daylight
i began
seeing in my room beings
surrounding me that were helping my body
to heal from from the shock
so
that experience
uh at five years old you don't know what
to call that
but it told me it literally shocked me
into an awareness
that i was not alone in the world and
that there are worlds that exist that i
couldn't see
under normal circumstances
and the only way i could see those
worlds was if i had the feeling that i
had
through that electrical jolt
and that experience stayed with me
and as i moved through life i learned
that that feeling the power of of my
ability to have a feeling when i wanted
to have a feeling
to be able to to feel that connection
and communicate if i needed to
communicate
with whatever those beings were i mean i
love talking about aliens i mean i talk
about it on my show and they always make
fun of me but i don't care because i
don't care you go to this camp and it's
a high um
vibrational kind of mountainous area
and they have
daily ufo
sightings i mean are aliens real yeah
yeah they are like
stop being stupid people like this this
is a big giant place we're not the only
game in town come on and like how much
fun are we down here of course they want
to join the party bro they're like duh
so as we're going there let's say there
may have been something that's zoomed by
let's just say there may have been i
don't know who knows okay anyways i go
out there uh and i meet with them i walk
into this room and there was about a
maybe a half dozen eight people there
they looked like they were 500 years old
i mean these are elderly people right
george fontes i guess him somewhere in
his 60s 70s 80s hard to tell anyways he
said oh welcome we've been expecting you
joan did you say something no he said
anyways we are the college of universal
wisdom and let's take you for a walk
they took me in the backyard there's
this giant monolithic uh
boulder out there right and there was a
house underneath they took me into the
house underneath and showed me some of
the equipment there and somebody was
living there they said we have a lot of
people coming over because there's a lot
of you know ufos that land here oh by
the way would you like to see what one
looks like sure and then they show me
pictures look at his backyard
anyways let me continue with the story
so they take me inside the integration
they say we need young people we'd like
you to be on our board of directors and
i said but i know very little about this
stuff they said you'll know believe me
trust us and the next year you'll know a
lot more okay cool so he takes me inside
this integration which you've been he
says
this came from them many
extraterrestrials or people you know are
not the kinds that we know and i'm
building it for their instructions and
what i'm going to do is i'm creating
inside a negative ion but a special type
of negative ion so the outside is
actually an electric motor when it's
done it's going to spin this way create
inside a negative ion and as people walk
through with cancer that cancer is going
to be gone it's going to boost up their
immune system so much it's going to cure
cancer by the time the government
murdered everyone
anyway so this is a very strange story
i'm not saying anybody who murdered who
but
oh gosh about 40
gosh it must have been
70
yeah right around 1976
i got a call
on my home phone we'd have cell phones
in those days from doris von tassel she
was a doctor slash kyra patterson's jp i
have some news for you but believe me
everything's okay
george died last night okay i want you
to come out here
i said well oh gosh he still he says
well jp i've already had his body
cremated
she could sign the certificate and
create his body so of course i went out
there and we said says george george has
left us and his wish was to be cremated
so we've it's been cremated already so
before the sun came up you know all of a
sudden george's cree made it right it's
not there anymore and she says uh
we're going through some changes right
now uh
we're gonna try and hang on this
integratron but there's a lot of forces
that don't think what we're doing is
right think it's a hoax and there's
others that know it's for real but don't
want us to finish i just want to let you
know that i don't know where the college
is going from here on out but the other
people i guess was the other members or
something said stay away for a while you
know and that was the last time i was
out there but that was developed as an
outside armature that spins around
creating negative ion force inside there
are three categories of things people
are talking about as if it is one
one is actual extraterrestrial
biological entities evens from other
star systems
that have craft etc
okay 100
they're not hostile 100 they're peaceful
100 they're way more advanced than we
are socially and in every other way
then there are the man-made phenomena
man-made ufos and man-made electronic
systems that simulate
e.t
and also things from other dimensions
like stranger things montauk
then you have actual
intelligences
and beings that are from another
dimension that are not extraterrestrial
got it okay now what is happening with i
call it cosmological indigestion it's
all getting mixed up
[Music]
is that
those all those categories because of a
lack of knowledge and discernment and
education
it's not you know
are being all
mixed together and conflated as one
thing that's very dangerous actually and
the intelligence community loves it
because they love for people to be
confused and deceived and they'd love
for people to believe
that some of these ets are these
malevolent negative energy sucking
things like an incubus or something
that we should be terrified of because
that justifies the war effort that
justifies the weapons in space
so this confusion
is deliberate
it's been fostered through
counterintelligence operatives in the
society
and one of the most difficult things
that i encounter all the time is
untangling for people
this
cosmological confusion well i for sure
have and i've also wished um and put
intentions out there for only the high
vibrational high density aliens to show
up so yeah blue aliens playing whatever
yeah as long as i'm high vibrational i'd
be like awesome then i'd be like then i
try to you know be telepathic with them
um i'm really most excited about their
technology
like
the technology that supposedly
which someday they're going to bring
they have brought let's not fool
ourselves they have brought
um
but i like the idea of the healing
technologies
that
are coming sitting in lawn chairs in the
middle of joshua tree in a circle with
stephen greer and doing a puja prayer
and all the stuff and um let's just say
like i saw it yeah i saw it and we had
contact like no confusing right we all
felt the temperature
around us raised by like 30 degrees
literally when you're in the desert at
night it's cold right so like the
temperature raised so high that we all
started sweating but it was in the
matter of like 10 seconds and what we
all saw was this giant ball of light
completely encompass us
and what he was saying was we were taken
aboard a ship
uh we are made with carbon-based life
carbon on the periodic table of elements
which you may remember from chemistry
class periodic table
carbon is the stickiest of all the
elements
it can make more kinds of molecules than
all other kinds of atoms combined
wow
so if you were to pick one atom off of
that table and base the diversity of
life on it
it would be carbon
it gives you the most variation the most
options the most experiments turns out
carbon
is one of the most abundant elements in
the universe
where the hell are all the people
welcome
not only that we've got oxygen in us and
nitrogen
we are made out of the most common
ingredient which is why we're stardust
it's no we start us not only
that's an aspect of why we're startups
we're stardust because those elements
the heavy elements in particular the
carbon the nitrogen the oxygen the iron
are made in the cores of stars
that explode scatter that enrichment
across the galaxy allowing the next
generation of stars to have those
elements that can make planets
and life
so
it's not
simply that we are in this universe
the universe is in us
yes
we are not
it's not just poetically true
it is literally true
that we are stardust
and so when we look for life in the
universe it's not unrealistic
to look for carbon-based life
it's just not
it's and plus we have an example of it
here
so how many other ways might there be to
be alive there could be many
but if you have a limited budget
and can design only one experiment
are you gonna pluck at random one of
these hundred ways that life might be
alive that you've never tested before
that you don't have any evidence of are
we going to try the one way we know that
life does exist
so we we're self-aware of that
limitation but it's not a crazy
limitation
to to operate on
it's not
so are aliens real
probably